the outlook isn't bleak at offensive
line after they got manhandled by the
tampa bay buccaneers in super bowl 55.
eric fisher wasn't available to play
tour and achilles tended in the afc
champions game mitchell mitchell
schwartz missed a lot of the season with
back issues
on thursday peter both guys abruptly and
surprisingly released in bang bang
fashion by the kansas city chiefs you
know i've been waiting for a stunner and
i don't know that this qualifies
but i was surprised this isn't one that
we expected i didn't expect both guys
much less either guy to go and there's
the thank you teams do that now thank
you for everything now please get the
hell out both mitchell schwartzand thank
you very much and now you are no longer
employed by this organization how
surprised were you when it happened
peter
very but then you hear that schwartz may
be needing another surgery and his
future could be uncertain
uh and
you know you don't know a guy who's
played as much
as eric fisher has who's got the cap hit
that he has
i mean how do you know
what kind of physical condition he's
going to be in coming back and look
i know that andy reed has bigger fish to
fry this off season
but
i know from years
of read watching
and you ask everybody who ever worked
with him going back to green bay but
certainly
starting in the late 90s when he was the
coach of the philadelphia eagles going
all the way through then
his trademark in the draft room
preparing for the draft is
you know always always always
have depth on the offensive line always
be prepared on the offensive line and
this year unfortunately for them
they get laurent duvernay tarde tardy
who opts out uh because he wants to
continue his medical career you know and
good for him because of covet up in
canada
and and then you know the the third
round pick who they drafted who also
opted out so they got
honestly the chiefs i'm not saying they
got blindsided but the chiefs thought
that they were going to have a little
bit
uh of a cushion on the offensive line
this year and it turns out by the end of
the year they didn't and mike let me
just tell you one thing
13 months ago when the kansas city
chiefs
played in the super bowl against you
know and really probably should have
beaten the san francisco 49ers but when
they played in that super bowl i mean
obviously they did beat the niners
excuse me but when they played in that
super bowl
the all five offensive linemen in that
super bowl every one of them could be
gone this year now duvernay tardif has
said publicly he wants to return and
play in this year we'll see if that
happens
but again this just goes to show you
you know in the old jerry glanville
thing nfl stands for not for long this
just goes to show you that you know in
the nfl you better be prepared for you
know the emergency beyond the emergency
and so the kansas city chiefs you talk
about all the things they need this this
off season
they better cut their cap a little bit
tight so that they can afford
uh you know a kevin zeitler something
like that in free agency
this coming off season
and i think that's the key when you
mention that kevin zeitler or whoever
else is going to be available the chiefs
projecting that they're going to have
more reliable options on the offensive
line than the guys they currently have
as players get cut by other teams as
free agents end up looking around
wondering where the big money is you
eventually accept the fact that you're
not going to get the big money you're
going to be lucky to have a job hey how
about go play for the chiefs play for
patrick mahomes it's easier to do a good
job on the offensive line when you have
a guy with patrick mahomes
mobility and elusiveness which he has
unlike most other quarterbacks currently
in the nfl so whether it's zeitler
whether it's nate soldier if it doesn't
work out with him as he comes back from
opting out and the giants clearly aren't
going to pay him 10 million dollars this
year there will be options out there for
the chiefs to bring in and improve their
offensive line and this is an exercise
rick spielman told me this last week the
long time gm of the vikings it is going
to be a constant exercise and and he
didn't put it quite this way but he
agreed with my characterization as guys
become available you're going to look at
who you have
and you're going to make some decisions
to get rid of some of the guys you have
and go out and get guys who are
available and i think the chiefs doing
this preemptively instead of waiting for
a guy to fall into their laps they have
the belief possibly because they've been
talking to people
you know during those conversations that
aren't supposed to happen that we know
every team engages in they have an idea
who they're going to get so they know
who they're gonna get we move on from
fischer and schwartz and our plan will
eventually reveal itself to anyone who's
paying attention as to who's gonna be
blocking for patrick mahomes next year
peter
you know there's a couple of positions
in free agency that to me
are surprisingly
robust
okay doesn't really surprise me that
you've got a lot of wide receivers
because quite honestly there usually are
good wide receivers most years in free
agency
but the couple of things that really
kind of interest me
like i think
where the kansas city chiefs are going
to need some help
there have been a lot of pretty good
offensive linemen who have either been
consigned to the scrappy or you know
quite
quite clearly have been cap cuts we
mentioned one of them uh
in
kevin zeitler of the giants the former
browns guard and to me
you know you've also got a really good
center one of the best centers in
football corey linsley um you know is is
on the list
what about joe thuney you know joe
tooney right now as you listen to what
the patriots might do it looks as though
they're going to basically sit on the
sidelines and make him go get a really
good offer
so there's a lot of players at the
positions of need
that the chiefs now they might have to
compete for some of them
but who knows what a phone call from
patrick mahomes might do
yeah absolutely and we're going to see
that this year i firmly believe the
opportunity for some of these teams to
become super teams where they can go out
and rent guys for a year at a low cost
as they wait for the salary cap to
rebuild itself next year once normalcy
returns for the nfl so you take a year
you chase a ring and then you go get
paid next year when things are back to
where they were supposed to be before
everything got turned upside down austin
writer the chief center also is expected
to sign elsewhere in free agency that
could open the door for corey linsley
all other things
relevant like caps base and contract and
who else may want lindsay but this is
going to be a strange
very strange free agency period the
stars still get paid
there just won't be as many who get paid
and we saw 10 franchise tags applied
this week those tags don't get applied
if their teams don't fear that there
would be the kind of offer in free
agency that they would be unable or
unwilling to match so stars will get
paid and there will be that parade of
press conferences and announcements and
teams reveling in the fact that they
have some some big name player that
joins the franchise but
other than those guys
the there's gonna be a lot of players
that get squeezed and that middle class
of recognizable
veteran name
those are the guys that are gonna be
bearing the cost peter of the losses
arising from the pandemic because all
the players got fully compensated last
year even though the nfl's revenue
reportedly was down four billion dollars
someone's got to pay the price for that
on the players side and it's going to be
that middle class of veterans this year
and there's gonna be a lot of guys
available and they're gonna end up
signing for a lot less money than they
ever thought they were gonna earn this
year
you said it a minute ago mike when you
said there will be a
there will be scads of one-year
contracts signed like you know one of
the guys who who i look at and one of
the guys we're going to be talking about
in our number two
is bud dupree
and you look at bud dupree and he's
coming off a year in which he exploded
early in the year he was great then he
gets hurt misses the rest of the season
so now nobody is really sure
if they're going to get vintage duck bud
dupree they probably will
but
he is the perfect candidate
to a guy to play 2021 to sing for his
supper and for his big long-term
contract when the cap goes up again in
2022 i think there's going to be
30 of those guys i mean usually there's
a few of them but this year i think
there might be more of those
than there will be of the the cj mosleys
you know the guys who
you know because only a few teams have
the money to give out these 80 million
dollar contracts which
surprise don't really become 80 million
dollar contracts
yeah it usually happens with the guy who
suffers the catastrophic injury like a
bud dupreeh this year it's going to
happen to guys who are perfectly healthy
who are just like
what what what the hell where's my i've
been working all these years for my
payday where is it it's not going to
happen this year for most of those guys
let's take a break when we return
where will the payday happen for juju's
miss schuster and is there a chance it's
gonna happen for him in pittsburgh by
the way will this be patrick mahomes's
life next year that would be difficult
even with his elusiveness i think that
would be a difficult thing for him to
pull off him and no one he doesn't even
have receivers
it's just 11 on one he'd probably get a
first down eventually
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports